like I said I'm giving you this for free
okay it's an unusual function I'm asking
the same question what's the maximum
what's the minimum okay now when you
have a look at this I'm in the
restricted domain here I'm giving you
the derivative right so you remember the
first thing we went for was Tommy where
the stationary points are the potential
ten points rather where the potential
turning points here minus three and one
however when you look at the restricted
domain negative three is outside of the
domain I'm interested so I reject that
okay so the only relevant turning point
occurs at x equals one
are you okay with that and I'm just
going to non-ideal okay I'm kind of
playing a little faster loose at the
moment I just want to get the picture to
you because once we get the picture
you'll see something very unusual now
I'm gonna do my table of values now okay
but something unusual comes out when we
do this okay how many columns am I going
to need
well I'm comparing X against Y I know
I've got to test at the end points my
left endpoint is zero I've got a
stationary point at one but then I don't
have an endpoint on the right-hand side
it just moves on forever okay now that's
kind of weird but I can understand
what's going on I'm still going to leave
a box for it as you'll see why in a
second okay have a look at this function
let's get back into Kurt sketchy mode
right what can you tell me about this
function and its extremities it's like
it's
it becomes zero what kind of it has a
horizontal asymptote right the way I
know it has some horizontal asymptotes
it's because the degree at the bottom is
bigger than the degree the top yet so as
I go to really really huge X this is a
moment is gonna get enormous right and
so I'm approaching zero so what I would
put here because I'm done it doesn't
have an import it does there have a
behavior that it does as I go further
and further and further
okay so that's important to me that we
factor into maximum all right sir
some values right when I put x equals
zero in just have a look at the numbers
x equals 0 that's 0 that's 0 it's a
thing ok again because it's pretty
simple when you put in 1 you're getting
1 + 1 + 1 + 3 that's 2 over 4 which is
1/2 okay and you guys already told me
that um this limit as I approach
infinity is 0
ok now before we draw some conclusions I
want a picture I want a picture right
what's this thing look like
pause for a second I haven't done the
second derivative I haven't done table
values for the first rivet either but I
already know what kind of stationary
point this is what kind of stationary
point is it can you see how I argue I
reason that it's a maximum because look
look start to draw the picture right at
x equals zero you're at a third at x
equals one you've got a stationary point
up at a half and then as X approaches
infinity you're going towards y equals
zero okay that have better be the top
right I can't accompany the bottom up
there's nothing up here right so
therefore this is my graph okay simple
enough now let's answer the question
easy one first what's the maximum the
max it is 1/2 it occurs at x equals 1
that's just quickly about that now
but now when we ask the question what's
the minimum we kind of run into the
problem okay
what's the obvious like first thing that
you would say you would say zero is the
lowest right cuz look like that's not
what I can't conquer boy that certainly
that's a minimum right except for the
problem just like when I said okay for a
point of inflection you need to have a
point right you can't have out of
discontinuity you can't say well then I
am cause it's discontinuous now when do
I get to y equals zero and the answer is
I don't ever get there right there's no
turning point which means that we move
up to the bottom okay I'm never gonna
get to zero so I can't say zero is my
minimum so therefore you say okay well
it's something above to earth right
we'll pick a number zero point zero one
well guess what I can get close up I can
get lower than that I can get zero point
zero zero one or zero point zero zero
zero one or any because it's asymptotic
any arbitrarily small value just above
zero right a [ __ ]
I can't I can't say it's that number and
I also can't say it's zero I can't say
it anything there is no minimum because
by definition the minimum is a number
right but there is no number that
actually satisfies the description of
the mineral can't be zero because you
can't get there it can't be any number
above zero cuz you'll always be able to
get lower than it right just like when
my son asked me Danny what's the biggest
number is it a hundred and I'm like I'm
good ones big guy and he's like what
about a hundred hundred doesn't know I'm
like oh wow you can always think of a
bigger number well in Reverse whatever
number you supply me so long as positive
and always be able to pick a smaller
number so there is no no mum there's no
minimum